Welcome back to another
We're gonna fight Towelie one of my favorite Southport characters of all time I'm very excited
Apparently he's an ex drug addict that now works at a drug store
You go which one town fun fact my my name casserta came from Towelie when he did that?
He's gonna end up getting high isn't he okay?
Fuck Kuhn is so worthless I hate him
Cartman is supposed to be the best character right. I don't know man and
My character is really bad, too. Honestly like my setup is so shit
Mike come on Mike our impression is some point
Yeah, I'm just gonna let Kuhn die cuz he's worthless good sesh kids
I'm gonna let him take it
Congratulations, I have a burrito then you fucking Coon
On fire you guys your leader is like burning up here
He's so great I love him
I'm just charging my ulti right now
Because that's what's gonna make a difference here this combat has a special objective. What really?
Most Commerce requires you to kill all enemies not this one - do we tell you must light all four weed piles on fire
Man I am way behind, I can't believe I didn't realize
Okay well, we'll keep moving then actually do you think I can just use my fire attack then I?
Can't use it there, but I can you see here, so maybe it will burn no
That isn't work come on
Come on
All right watch places with him and then burn one of the wheel there you go
Why are there piles of weed anyway who knows?
Ok I get it now
You're the only one that can light up the path
Oh
My god my lord fuck you
What kind of black magic oh my god, what's
It's hand that's be forgiving and all slaves free oh nice. That was such a weird episode
And then we got one more, let's just walk over nice and easy
We did it
Nothing happened though all right, let's get real lit in this beer hey radius I
Did the admission what is happening there we go the best attack?
Yes out of it
You
All right we did it I
Guess it only works on Towelie like it doesn't affect us for some reason back
Up now get some granddaddy purple shatter on the house come by any time for
You know we should count very names
Finally we have that medicinal fried chicken. I understand it was KFC. They were referencing him, so stupid
He didn't hit me at all
But oh well, what can you do?
We're gonna get back to class see the clients this gal in 10 while we're at it, though. Why don't we test that Callos ability?
See what we can get sorry, that's the wrong, buddy
Just a quick little investigation see way if it's worth then
Wait we have to get there first I can't be bothered
Excuse me. Do you want to take a selfie?
Okay great. I'm glad we agree on things
now
classy
Okay classes should be here
Plastic should be here, and it's gonna be nice. It's gonna be a good champ. Everybody a good time
I tell you Wow man the PlayStation is so slow my god
Here's a new kid now you got class. He's prescription damn well better hand my prescription when it's about motherfucking time
Praise Jesus. I need this shit, babe. If I don't get my medication. I lose my motherfucking mind
You know what I'm saying. I know what you're saying
Don't worry girl. I got you, man
The place y'all niggas need to go is you story, that's where they taking the cast you know what I'm saying
I know what you're saying. This is lettuce the new kid got the Intel from Clancy not bad. New kid. What'd you find out?
It's the used orange in the northeast of him classy says the cats are being taken day. They use storage
We should have known all right Kate classy safe. I'll get back to you guys soon Roger that
Okay, so we got to go to the northeast side of town oh
The cab singing hey kid you're voting vigilante from the news right that ain't me me
Not a talker huh well sergeant wants to have a few words with you over at the station
No, I don't wanna go to this dashing well, I guess we gotta cooperate be a good set of sin you know
Craig
Okay, yeah, oh my god, what yeah, so it turns out gender is actually a little more
Complicated than what we talked about yesterday. Okay? Could you come back to my office so we could sort this out, maybe, huh?
New do you guys want to take a selfie, I know you do, oh, that's a great one hahaha I
Already taken with these bitches, okay?
Talk to mr. Mackey, maybe we'll pick whatever is closer. All right, whatever. This is do it
Brake seems so far away. Oh wait we can't go here because the sixth grader
Well I think I killed him
Time fartole I see you oh of course we can pause the time cart
So how did we do that again, okay?
Now that didn't work
I
Use the wrong time fart, sorry
This is the right time fun
There we go, okay
How about that okay now we can talk to counselling okay?
Our discussion about
gender
Wasn't a precise enough and well you gave me some guidelines how to do a more thorough?
Path helping you identify your gender my regret so much picking on there now. This is just annoying
Yes, male yes female no
That means it means your gender fluid what is happening right now the next thing
I want to talk to you about with your gender is your sexuality
Now a lot of people think that gender and sexual art of design, but know that bud is mad, okay
How would you describe the sex of the kinds of people you find yourself sexually attracted to
Are you attracted to both binary genders male and female, or do you find multiple genders beyond the binary definitions attract
Sexually attracted to some genders or all genders
And
Sexual gender fluid yes
Well I'm glad we sorted that out
Just be careful
Okay
because there's there's a lot of people out there who don't accept you for what you are and
You're gonna have to deal with them. Okay, so uh, but come see me anytime
Good talk principal. Thank you very much
Domo arigato, what a great talk I really feel like we did a lot there. Oh my god so much homework tonight
Hey that queer kid oh my God
We're gonna kick their ass again
Teach you to make fun of gender fluid pansexual people, okay, thank you
Beautiful very nice, okay, we're done
Mix up police station
Here we go let's enjoy
Okay, so talk to Detective Harris
What are you supposed to be a rodeo clown good one a long, throw good one. Okay? Let's go
Oh, hi guys
You're the one who made the news last night, huh
That's me the police can always use the help of concerned citizens
I guess we can give our little junior detective a special kitty case to work on all right. Thank you
There's somebody new to town shaking up the crime family. Oh, man. This is a real bad
Dude a kingpin of crime it wants to control all the drug that doesn't sound like a small giant into this location here
I need you to go in and neutralize them you lead point my boys will be there after
If you take out the drug kingpin will give you this junior detective badge pretty neat, huh?
Really neat made a gigantic Guinea. This is a sidequest sir main quest
I can't tell it's all it's all merch in this one. I see I think it's a main question
Doesn't pay crime doesn't pay who are you supposed to be a drum major?
He doesn't take sell food just anyone how about that?
and wonder what happens if you take a selfie with
Everyone in the game cuz that just seems like a lot of work
And I don't really get what you get out of it all right we can Fastpass
There's not enough Fastpass in the game. You gotta walk a lot man. I
Wish I wouldn't mind, but the loading screen between each one is like ah dude all right
Here we are at tweakin Bros. I love Twiggy. It's such a fun character
Hello welcome to tweet copy what can I interest you in today and Aksum nash?
Mochaccino, please sorry young man, I can only take selfies with customers. I will then ash
It's like putting on your favorite flannel shirt
Was a pleasure well, it sure was a pleasure they had to meet you there. Yes, oh
My god wife. They're really going hard on the fan fiction stuff
Sorry what was my mission find the suspect but
It wasn't there quite. Oh wait. He's outside my bed. Okay. Okay? Okay? Okay? What is it? What do they say?
My batter has to talk to Craig all right listen
I have this expert who I hate now, and he still has my goddamn laptop go get it from him
But tell him if he doesn't let you have it. I'm calling the fucking cops
Davis tweek you'll probably fight about his parents coffee house
Get my fucking laptop back for that prick is that in here?
My god, I was just there today. I need my laptop back for some reason there you go
We need to come up with the perfect sunset blend
Okay, well, I guess we're just gonna go back then and talk to Craig about the guinea pig
Did I tell you I used to have a guinea pig? I think I did
Tweek say about my laptop
Fine you know wear stripes cages go get up and give them to that fucking asshole
Finally when you give that to tweek you make sure he toes that when you walk out on someone
You don't get to make up the rules anymore
So they really weren't dating, huh?
Wow Matt, it's an interesting
Didn't see that one coming, okay, so I'll do it later. We I don't want to walk all the way back to then go
Even though that was a fast fast pants
Where are you telling me? I can't go here
Now I can go here, okay, okay, I forgot you have to follow the the law
No, I really I'm done fighting okay, I'm tired let me just
Let me just do this quest right now
Throw more imaging is showing the suspect is in the rear of the house
Okay, what is this quest? Oh?
My god, it's in the rear of the house. This is it boys
Am I gonna fight this guy just oh, this is a drug-dealing
All right
We can if this one is really good
Just stabbed with a butter knife returned it back of course of course that shadow okay? Well that was an easy kill
I don't teach you to corrupt. Are you good?
Let me just kill a random I
Think I know what's gonna happen
This town has to deal with please come by and help us again
We did it let's loot his house while we're at it
Cuz that's what you do after you go into someone's house and beat them up in
the name of the law
You betray the law law
You know that reference okay? Otherwise, it sounds really cringey
Yes
Why so many loading screens so awkward
Okay, yeah, we're okay Nia. I wish you could fast travel anywhere
Go to crunchy microbrew. Okay. That's our next question al
Yeah, okay, yeah well
I wonder fucking actually no
See there's a fast path right here anyway
Need to get somewhere oh my god, yes
Take me here
The Fastpass is not a fast pace. Okay. It comes in and he's like II we
And there's a loading screen you have to walk to the right place
And then you have to walk from there like I don't know man. I don't know man
I wish you could pick not just the fast fastest but
Whatever, okay? I'll make the rules. Oh my god. You're slow
Super Craig ouch, okay, yeah, and we need to still fill out our character sheet of course
Now you got a problem with me ah piece of Prisma and do nothing while you insult this man's ethnicity
I wasn't insulting him excuse me. Did you or did you not say that this man seemed tired yes. He's my friend
I said Paulo you look tired
Backgrounds have been stereotyped as being sleepy. Oh, yeah shares a microaggression that will not turn, but I am
You you're the new kid right I'm the principal of your school my name is PC principal
I was told you wanted to talk to me about some race issues. Okay, come at me
Why?
Why are we fighting in?
Nothing's happening come on you want to learn about rape right give me your best shot
I don't think we can kids nice day. Isn't it tough?
Wait why is wrong with you you can't just attack for no reason try again, but I
It's a nice day. Isn't it? Oh?
Stop wrong with you you can't just attack for no reason try again, okay? I'm not gonna do anything
Not gonna do anything. I'm not doing anything. Yes very good. That was indeed not a microaggression
all right round two
What I ate a hamburger last week oh
I have to spot the microaggression. Okay, okay, okay, okay?
You will see how it gives you a free shot
Only for the use of training this young person in the ways that the social justice warrior. Thank you Michael Christian about to happen
My friend Brian looks like a chick like Mike with drinks Saturday brunch in damn
Not only is the word chick derogatory to females, but also criticizing a male for looking feminine as a microaggression
Towards personal transgender now, let's see if you can spot on micro aggression. It's more subtle. Oh, okay pants are born
My pants are warm. Is that a microaggression?
I don't think so that copy belongs to Tim Sherman now. It's not a microaggression. I heard it's going to rain
No, that's not a microaggression
Janet likes to roller-skate my crap now. What's wrong with you. You can't just attack for no reason try again. What okay? All right?
Genet likes to roll her skin fine. It's not a microaggression. I don't know mr.. Yamashiro is actually a very good driver dancer microexpression
hit
His punching tan
Very nice indeed
Using the term actually inferred that maybe other Asian Americans are not good drivers and the use of Mister is offensive to persons a third
Gender now before we talk about your race. I need you to get out there and do some PT work for me
I'll let you know when I think you're ready
that was amazing I
Love this game only we'll only South Park will make those kind of jokes
That's my job, just about the microaggressions can't seem to leave this house there we go
Everywhere I go left and right there's microaggressions that I have to deal with this just wears my cows. It's my duty
That's the thing with social justice warrior. They think it sounds cool. So they're like ya know. I'm standing up for social justice
Meanwhile everyone is laughing at them
All right, oh, yeah, we talked to Detective Harry's okay, cuz we attacked that man
African-american get mad. Thank you
Hello yes
Back for more I got something you might be interested in
Turns out that scum. You fucked up is just the low guy on the totem pole. Oh, okay, I see
Is over here the real
Hey, oh yeah, that happens to be any token town
He's hiding out some big luxury mansion bought with blood money come back
This is a whole nother level little crime fighter his house is like a fortress and we maneuvered door is wired to a state-of-the-art
High-tech security system you'll need this
It's a microphone
I think we're just gonna break in and
Attack black people. I think that's the mission here because it's tokens housing first ten. Yep. It's definitely whatsapp
This is that wrong on many levels, and I do not go by it stand by it
I will not I am a social justice worry now
Look I have to go all that way, but there's no fast pass. There's no there's no fast pace. Well well
Well the power of editing. We'll do this one just fine
We go
Piss break or something proceed past the gate and around the back to find an entry point what in the world is happening there?
I will fuck you up non-lethal eeee. I will beat you until my shift is over sir what yet he has a baton
Defeat the security team others. There's a team
That's time what uh-huh
Oh
Wow who should we take out first then him were
Actually we could infect somebody
You didn't get your
Oh
wow
That was really tough. Oh my god. I took a long time. I barely got through but that was tough, man
Oh me oh my potato pie that oh gee. I'm sweating
I'm playing on the hardest men
Mastermind I
Probably shouldn't have picked mastermind
because I am NOT a
mastermind
My god the challenge the challenge that I have to go through while you guys
Move the hacking device to the location HUD spots oh
My god, I'm doing all kinds some hacking over here
Yes, everything is just fine surging
Move the land land to the hacking device
That's great
No problem sir continue hacky
My god wow what a PHP transcoded?
This is so dumb
Did you maybe write the password down anywhere sir like a notepad or something yes, yes must be something
Let's see let me check in this drawer. Not again
Hold on
One more hack. Thank God. They told you Jesus. What is the point of this?
Good old matrix
I don't understand how it's gonna end
Hey, Lilly, tack it Matt guide. We put the microphone next to the cellphone
a
middle name
Okay
So I tell you what let's just look up your account profile and get a new password for you if you can just hang on
Oldest trick in the book oldest trick in the book
Well if this is upper-middle class and you can't damn boy
It's got some whiskey he's richer. I wish you should take all this stuff
This is tokens house rich kid
What am I doing here come on I need to find the right room damn it every nice
Moment hey who the hell are you you can't just break in here
Uh a really system you know and we're just gonna beat up another black guy cuz I don't know about this guy's
Please just leave oh he's strong
And nuts Oh ace tokens dead chokehold him
What do you want I want you to die
Oh
well, well we're
Tapped this is messed up man. This is messed up
Brilliant work here. Oh, you're really getting into the program well
I'm kind of perfectly what we're doing and you're doing it right along with us. Meet me back at the station
I've got something for you. Oh, I can't wait. What do we got for us?
Wait, that's the party vigilante
That's a good 40 come a little closer
You guys are dinner
I'm gonna crush you pussy like
Microaggression
Wait I get the punch sink is it in my creek
I got attacked on the way to the police station my god
Thanks for dressing man that six Raider either. I'm not going to why but the words crush and pussy trigger and particularly we're a
Particularly negative reaction from me
Jimmy you've been fairly clear in the past that you're tolerant views and fight for social justice are to help you and I quote
crush push
Goddamn, Jim quit victimizing me Oh
Social media what have you done what have you done social media?
Who are you supposed to be dork man, okay here we are
At the police station, let's see what he got for me. I'm excited
In the next episode thank you guys so much for watching leaving it like all this port has been amazing
I love it. It feels like 2013 PewDiePie all over again
Thank you guys
bro fish squid BAM